abone ol
[Müzik]
çok
az önce arkadaşlara bir şey söyledim
acaba şöyle mi başlasam konuşmaya 18
dakikalık bir vaktiniz varsa iki buçuk
saatlik bir şey anlatacağım
Çünkü
Normalde benim kendi derslerimde de bol
bol anlattığım tema Aslında bugüne de
çok uyuyor o yüzden de
bundan birazcık sizlere bahsetmek
istedim şimdi biraz şunu odaklanalım
istiyorum
Bizi biz yapan şey nedir
Bu bir düşünün Lütfen bizi biz yapan şey
yani şöyle bir dönüp geçmişimize
baktığımızda dediğimizde Aslında nereye
bakıyoruz bir film şeridi gibi
gözlerimin önünden geçti dediğimizde
gözlerimizin önünden geçen şeyler ne ne
anılarımız
Allah bizi biz yapan şey geçmişimiz
kendi geçmişimiz ve anılarımız bugün
burada olmamızı sağlayan şey ben size
bugün biraz kendi anılarından bahsetmek
istiyorum Bu biraz önce dinlemiş
olduğumuz serüven
nasıl gerçekleşti ve bir oyuncu
eğitimine nasıl dönüştü mü
sizlere Break anlatacağım öncesinde
benim sormak istediğim küçük bir şey var
hatırlaya bildiğimiz en net hatırla ya
bildiğiniz en eski anıyı
bu çağırdığınızda aklınıza neler geliyor
en eski anınız en net hatırladığınız
Şimdi ben
o kendi hatırlaya bildiğim en net
anılarımdan birini size aktaracağım
Umarım seversiniz dileyenler gözlerini
kaplayabilir
1987 yılında Edirne'de güzel sıcak bir
sonbahar sabahı sen Edirne'de Kurtuluş
İlkokulu'nun bahçesinde yiz bizce
bulaşan çocuklari patlayanlar koşanlar
birdirbir oynayanlar var orada o
çocukların arasında
çok küçük sarışın bir olan var hadi
beyti
o orada duruyor
ve o sırada
okulun kapısından çıkan bir öğretmen
tiyatroya gidecekler sıraya girsin diyor
bu ve sizde beyti ile birlikte gidip
koşarak sıraya giriyorsunuz
ve ardından öğretmen önde Siz arkada
devam ederken
okul bahçesi ile okul duvarı arasındaki
koridordan yavaşça aşağı iniyorsunuz ve
sonra
ve o yokuşun ağzındaki açılan Demir
kapıdan
bambaşka bir bahçeye çıkıyorsunuz
kocaman ağaçlar o mis gibi toprak kokusu
ve bahçenin ortasında kocaman eski bir
tiyatro binası var o binanın büyük ahşap
kapılarından içeriye doğru girdiğinizde
muhteşem bir uğultuyla karşılaşıyorsunuz
Siz yaşlarda
yüzlerce çocuk içeride
Öğretmeninizin gösterdiği yere doğru
ilerliyorsunuz oturuyorsunuz ve
karşınızda sahne
o çocuk oyunu için hazırlanmış dekorlar
var
ve yavaşça Işıklar sönüyor ve oyuncular
sahnedeki yerlerini alıyorlar
bu işte tiyatro ile tanıştığım
o ilk anlardan ve tiyatro ile ilgili ilk
anılarından biri buydu
sonrasında hemen büyük bir hızla okumayı
çözüp 1. sınıfta ardından okuma
Bayramı'nda bir tavşan olarak sahneye
Çıktım
hemen ardından tiyatro merakım
gelişmişti Edirne Halk Eğitim Merkezi
idi Okulumuzun yanındaki tiyatro binası
ve sahidende Okulumuzun içinden halk
eğitim merkezine hiç trafiğe çıkmadan
geçilen bir Geçit vardı Ve bu yüzden de
beklediğini en çok tiyatro izleyen
okullardan biri bizlik ve ve ardından
ortaokul yıllarında mikrofonla
tanışıklığım başladı ve o günden beri
tanışıklığımız devam etmekte hala
çantamda bir mikrofonla Sürekli her an
her gün her yerinde dublaj yapmam
gerekebiliyor o yüzden de mikrofonla
tanışıklığımız da böyle devam ediyor
ardından lise yıllarına doğru edin
dediğine sana tiyatrosunu eden Halk
Eğitim Merkezi öğrencileri olarak edebi
sanatları bir grup bir ayaklandırdı ve
Edirne'de popüler bir genç haline
gelmeye başladık gerçekten de değil
severek yaptığım bir meslekle popüler
bir hale gelmek beni oldukça mutlu
etmeye başlamıştı Demek ki İyi de
yapıyordum ki insanlar bana güzel
tepkiler vermeye başlamışlardı ve böyle
böyle yavaş yavaş benim içimde küçük bir
balon şişmeye başladı oyunculuğa da
yapıyorum Yapıyorum gayet de güzel
yapıyorum diye devam eden sürecin
sonunda
1999 yılında
Edirne'nin en başarılı oyuncularından
biri olarak konservatuar sınavına Tabii
ki kim girecekti ben ve Edirne'den
kalkıp önce Eskişehir Anadolu
Üniversitesi ardından Ankara
Üniversitesi Dil Tarih Coğrafya
fakültesinin sınavlarına kaydoldum ve
Eskişehir'in sınavı ile Ankara'nın ki
çakışıyor diye Eskişehir'e girmen Nasıl
olsa Ankara'yı kazanıyorum diyerek
Eskinin sınavına Girmedim Sonra
ikisinide kazanamadım Bu yıl dediğim
gibi 99 du ve ardından
ben tek bir seçeneğim kalmıştı
İstanbul'da Müjdat Gezen Sanat
Merkezi'nin sınavına girebiliyor Çünkü
ön kayıt yaptırmadan da Sınava
girebiliyorsunuz geldim ve
Edirne'den O şişkin ego mu Tabii ki bana
diyordu ki
zaten kazanırsın herhalde artık O kadar
da değil yani yeteneksiz değilsin diye
düşünüyorum derken kazanamadım ama o
sırada da İstanbul'da bir evli tutmuştum
ve bu sebeple İstanbul'daki bu evinde
yaşamaya başladım aradan bir buçuk ay
falan geçti Babam bugün dedi ki
bekleyeceğim Ne yapıyorsun Dedim ki evde
makarna yapıyorum baba
anladım ki oyunculukla ilgili kendim bir
adım atamıyorum Babam geldi bir özel
okulda
oyunculuk okumamı sağladı yani özel
olarak açılmış diyalog şimdi bir kursta
bir yol oyuncu oyunculuk eğitimi aldım
Türkiye'nin çok önemli hocalarından ve
bir eğitim en büyük katkısı var
ve hemen ardından O Yaz seslendirme
yapmaya başladım yani başladım derken
daha çok şöyle bir şeyden bahsediyor
olabiliriz benim başladığım yıllarda
sabah 10'da gidip seslendirmeye akşama
kadar izliyordum ben ve birileri geliyor
çıkıyor Onu seslendiriyor bunu
seslendiriyor ve ben sürekli onları
izliyorum İzliyorum izliyorum ve bir
yandan da böyle bir Hani o zannetmeyin
ki şişkin egom
yani tuzla buz oldu O hala yerinde
duruyor ve bir anlamda diyorum güzel bir
şey de yapmıyor ben de yapabilirim ya ne
olacak yani giriyorlar konuşuyorlar ben
de yapabilirim derken 3 ay sonunda bir
içeri aldılar sağolsunlar veriler ki Bey
cicim repliğin bu ve ben repliği gördüm
içeride yanımda oturan dublajı abilerde
var Onlar da benim ilk defa bu işi
yapıyor olmama Tanık olacakla gelen
ettik şuydu bu prototipleri alıp başka
prototipler ile karşılaştırıp devam eden
yeni prototipler elde ediyoruz
F12 tekrarın sonunda yapabilmiş kendi
İçerdeki dublajlı abiler artık arkadaşı
dışarı alsak mı Hadi çıksın demeye
başladılar ve böylelikle dublaj
kariyerinde En azından şimdilik sona
ermişti ardından tekrar konservatuar
sınavına girmem gerekiyor çünkü
İstanbul'da oturuyorum ve İstanbul'da
yaşamaya başladım içinde İstanbul'da
konservatuarlı demeyecektim İstanbul
Üniversitesi Devlet Konservatuvarı
sınavına girdim kazanamadım
ve ardından Mimar Sinan Üniversitesi
şimdiki adıyla Mimar Sinan Güzel
Sanatlar Üniversitesi Devlet
Konservatuvarı sınavına girmek üzere
kendimi
hazırladım Ama artık söyledim
Olmazsa da olmaz
ama çok da önemli değil yani artık
İstanbul'da yaşıyorum seslendirme
yapıyorum
web ve Tamam büyük ihtimalle olmayacak
Aman bir sınava girdim
ve Okulu kazandı Bugün birazcık bu
rahatlıktan bahsetmek istiyorum Yani
artık hepimizin bu
Olmazsa da olmaz diyebilecek rahatlığa
Erdi imizde Aslında hepsinde Yani bütün
hayat anlamında çok daha rahatladı ımızı
ve çok daha ferah bir aşamaya geçtiğimiz
anlatmak istiyorum ama sanmayın ki o
içindeki bir balonu
yine ne Okulu kazandım ve söndü Hayır
daha da büyüdü büyümeye devam etti
Okuldaki ilk yılın boyunca ben tamamen
bütün eğitmenlerine kendini kanıtlamaya
çalıştım bakın Ne kadar iyiyim beni
almakta ne kadar İyi yaptınız ne kadar
iyi oldu değil mi beni aldığınız ben çok
yetenekli değil mi hocam gerçekten çok
iyi değilim Sizce de bir Baksanıza
Berken
ve oyalım tamamen öğretmenler üzerinde
bir görünür olma çabası ve hangi eğitime
neyin nasıl oynanmasını seviyorsa onu
öyle oynamaya çalışan bir beyti olarak
ben okulda var oldum ve Sınıfta Kaldı
Çünkü bu hiç işe yaramıştı
ardından yine seslendirme yapmaya
başladım Çünkü konsollar kazandım diye
hemen seslendirmeye bırakmıştım Halbuki
yaptım en son şey prototipi ama gene de
havalı bir şey de bırakmak
O yüzden de hemen tekrar geri döndüm ve
seslendirme de o yaz Gerçekten çok
başarılı işlere imza attım bir tonda
zaten biliyorsunuz biliyorsunuz zaten
göreceksiniz anlamıştım İbo dicarlo
Vahşi Güzel isimli bir dizide kendisine
265 bölüm boyunca seslendirdim Adam
Sandler net bambıno yaz gerçekten
bunların hepsini bir anda
yapmaya başladım ne oldu Ne değişti
derseniz Kanal D Vahşi Güzel dizisi için
11 demo aldı ve oadammoda beni tercih
etti beni tercih edince ben dublajı
öğrenmek zorunda Kalsın Bu yüzden de o
yaz boyunca gerçekten güzel bir şekilde
ilerleyen dublaj kariyerinin ardından
tekrar bir bütünleme sınavı vardı Ve
ben yine herhalde bırakmazlar canım Yani
benim gibi adamı da bırakacak değiller
derken bıraktılar
[Kahkaha]
gerçekten
o ana kadar en başta öfkeyle doldum Ne
yapacağımı bilemedim nasıl ilerleyin
bilemedim ve ve Okulu bırakmayı düşündüm
yani çünkü ben sınıfta kalmış değildim
onlar beni bırakmış vardı mı Her zamanki
gibi o yüzden de
tekrar
okula gitmek istemedim bu bu okulun beni
hak etmediğini düşündüm falan düşünür
Yani oralar dayım kafa olarak ve ve
sonrasında okumaya başladıkça sınıf
arkadaşlarım ve aileme ısrarıyla okula
tekrar geri döndüm ve okumaya başladım
bu sefer Şunu fark ettim aradığım şey
başkaydı Sorduğum sorular bambaşkaydı ve
ve bundan sonraki bu iki yıllık süreç
içerisinde sürekli ben sorular sormaya
başladım ve bu sorular Aslında beni bana
çevirdiler Ben artık birinci yılındaki
gibi hangi hoca Neyi nasıl seviyorsa onu
öyle oynamaya çalışmaktan vazgeçip Ben
neyi nasıl oynamayı seviyorsun peşine
gittim çünkü Hayatımdaki en önemli
sorulardan biri buydu
ben bu işi yapıyorsam bu işten keyif
almalıyım ben bu işi zaten keyif aldığım
için yapıyorum Çünkü oyunculuk gerçekten
keyif almadığınız da çekilecek çile
değil yani sürekli birilerinin karşısına
çıkıp sürekli başarısız oluyor olma
hissinin ne getirebileceğini düşün ve bu
yüzden de bu sorularla geçen sürecin
sonunda
üstüne bir darbe daha vurulması
gerekiyordu ve bir Ocak ayının
başında İstiklal Caddesi'nde Kız
arkadaşımla buluşmak için üstünde ince
bir gömlek ve o zaman olan saçlarım bir
yenilenmiş yeni duş alınmış ve çıkmışken
soğuk bir Ocak günü yüz felci geçirdim
A101 hız durdu üç buçuk ay boyunca ya üç
buçuk ay boyunca taşlarımı
kaldıramıyorum gözümü kırpamıyorum
burnumu çektim de bunu bu tarafa
gelmiyordu ve
dudaklarımı bu kısmını oynamıyordu bu şu
demek çorba içtiğinizde tamamen
dökülüyor olması gerekiyor ve
Ve apar topar alıp Edirne'ye götürüldü
Edirne'de her sabah Fizik Tedavi
görüyorum ve sürekli işte kaşlarımı
kaldırıyorum gözlerimi sıkıyorum burnumu
çekiyorum ağzına işte öpücük yolluyorum
gülümsüyorum falan her sabah öyle
geçiyor Ve sonunda şuraya geldim ben bu
mesleği yapamayacağım herhalde
bu çünkü konuşurken
Hepsi gidiyor çünkü buraya hakim
olamıyorum ve sadece teknik rol
oynayabilirim ağzı yamuk adamlar
oynayabilirim Ne yapabilirim Ve bunu
nasıl başka bir şey çevirebilirim derken
Gerçekten tekrar
Sen beni kurtaracak tek şeyin kendi
sevdiğim meslek kendi sevdiğim şeyi
yapmak olduğunu fark ettim ve orada süre
No 2 aylık sürecin sonunda tekrar
İstanbul'a döndüm provalara devam etmeye
başladım ve aynaya bakarak kendime şu
sordum hatırlıyorum ağzı yamuk bir
adamla ben ne yapabilirim
ben bu ağzı yamuk adamdan ne
çıkarabilirim ve ben Boğazı yamuk Adamın
sesi birazcık daha böyle olabilir diye
düşündüm bu sesi dedi ki sanki biraz
daha göbekli bir adam olsa daha iyi olur
Ondan sonra hemen gittim yastığı kestim
tenime büyük bir bebek yaptım attım
yastıktan artan bir şeyler oldu dedim ki
bu adamın acaba omuzlarda mı yüksek olsa
hemen kalan yastık parçalarından oraya
bir şeyler ekledim ve ardından sahiden
şöyle bir adam ortaya çıktı
bu yıl
2004v ben gördüğünüz gibi orada bir adam
oynuyorum şu an tüm kariyerini O adam
oynamaya borçluyum çünkü
ve bunu izleyen başka bir yönetmen beni
davet etti profesörün hayatımda ilk
orada oynadım o yönetmenin davet ettiği
oyunda oynayan başka bir oyuncuyla başka
bir film çektim ondan sonra başka bir
yer açıldı ve bütün hayatın Aslında bu o
sırada olumsuz zannettiğim ve kendimi
içine hapsettiğim
oy verecen nem sayesinde oldu bazen
ve bütün bu süreçlerin sonunda
anlıyorsunuz ki Eskiden Cehennem
zannettiğiniz yerler İyiki varlar ve
orada aldığınız dersler gerçekten de iyi
ki var olmaya devam edecekler şimdi
yapıyor olduğum şeyse İnsan adet filmi
izleyenlerin iz biliyordur Orada büyük
anı kürelerini büyük labirentlerin büyük
kütüphanelerin içinde Anılar olarak
saklıyorlar Muhtemelen görmüşsünüzdür bu
alanda yapılmış hafıza alanında yapılmış
çok fazla çalışmalar var ve özellikle e
ortaya çıkan şey şu ki Anılar
değiştirilebilir Anılar yeniden
yapılandırılabilir ler Eğer onlar
yeniden yapılandırılabiliyor sabiz
oyuncular kendi kullanmaya
oyunculuk sırasında kullanmaya
çalıştığımız anılarımızda niye kendi
anılarımız dan faydalanıyoruz sorusu
geldi en son aklıma Ve burada da
oyuncularla birlikte karaktere ait yeni
Anılar yaratabilir miyiz sorusunu sorduk
Uzman Psikolog Filiz Kaya ile birlikte i
2005 yılından bugüne kadar
geliştirdiğimiz karakter tasarım
aşamasında oyuncuların kullanabileceği
birçok araçta oyuncuları bir kısmında
sahte anılarda yaratarak karakteri
hazırlıyoruz O yüzden de anıların ve
sahte anıların Dünya üzerinde ne kadar
yer kapladığını ve Aslında ne zamandır
hayatımızda olduğunu
sizlere anlatmak istedim Çünkü işinize
yarayacağını düşündüğüm bir şey var
eziyet Lotus 1974'ten beri yaptığı
araştırmalarda sahte Anılar üzerine
çalışıyor ve yaptığı araştırmaları ve
deneyleri
ilgiyle takip ettiğinizde Aslında birçok
şeyi fark etmeye başlıyorsunuz oyunculuk
alanında ise oyunculuk adına yapılmış
tek bir deney var ne yazık ki
nörobilimsel anlamda bu deneyde
araştırmacılar şunu söylüyorlar
oyuncular genelde bütün oyunculuk
yöntemlerinin arasında içten dışa ile
dıştan içe arasında sıkışıp kalmış
durumdalar ve
bu olarak karakteri hazırlayanları
incelediklerinde ortaya çıkardıkları
sonuç şu bunun için çeşitli sorular
soruyorlar Siz bu sorulara önce karakter
önce kendiniz adına belki olarak sonra
karakter adına Bence Romeo şöyle bir
adam sonrasında ise tamamen karakter
adına cevap veriyorsunuz ve zihinsel bir
hazırlık sonrasında Buna cevap
veriyorsunuz burada e ortaya çıkan sonuç
bize şunu söylüyor bir fiyat ver Bir
Oyun esnasında bir karakteri
canlandırmanın deaktivasyonu işleyen bir
süreç olduğunu ve belki de bir Kendini
kaybetme durumu olduğu söylenebilir
bu işte bu noktada
birazcık daha kendi anılarımızı ve kendi
travma larımızı demektense karaktere ait
yeni halılar yaratmak her zaman
oyuncuların daha çok içine gelecektir
diye düşünüyorum
şu hemen bu noktada önem gereken bir şey
var psikolog Filiz kayanın önerdiği
Tengri anılarımıza Lütfen bir Leon
arasında bir Değer verin bir hiçbir şey
hissettirmiyor bana şu anda gayet iyiyim
on sağ Gerçekten bugün çok kötü
hissetmemi sağlıyor on yıl önce olmuş
olsa bile hala Bugün kötü hissetmemi
sağlıyor dediğiniz yer olsun işte bu
noktada yapmamız gereken şey şu bu değer
verdiğiniz anılardan
15 ve üzerinde puan verdiklerinizi
lütfen oyunculuk çalışmalarında ya da
herhangi bir kişisel gelişim
çalışmasında kullanmayın sizi rahatsız
eden anılarımızla uğraşmayı herkesin
anısı gendicine de kalsın
ve size önereceğim bir şey var dediğim
noktaya geldim şunu yapabilirsiniz
gelecek anıları yaratabilirsiniz güzel
yarınlar için için de Sizinde olduğumuz
sevdiklerinizin de olduğu güzel gelecek
anıları yaratın Çünkü aslında Anılar
Bizi biz yapan şeyler ve onlar zedelenme
ip Biricik olduklarında o kürelerin
içinde saklanmaya değecek şeyler çok
teşekkür ederim